That Hadoop job command we typed was pretty painful to have to remember.
So to save you time, we've created an alias in the demo virtual
machine that you'll be downloading. You can just type hs followed by four
arguments, the mapper script, the reducer script,
the input directory, and the output directory.
Here's one important thing to note, though. When
you're running a Hadoop job, the output directory must
not already exist. And as you can see, if we try and run the command with an
existing directory. In this case, job output. Hadoop
refuses to run the job. This is actually a
feature of Hadoop. It's designed to stop you inadvertently
deleting or overwriting data that's already in the cluster.
But as you can see, if we specify a different directory,
which doesn't already exist, then the job will begin just fine.